Here's the answer. 3 has type int. 3, once, we have the dot. Now, it's not an
integer, it's a float. And we've seen things behave differently, like division
when our values have the dot after them. The reason for that was division
defined on floats means something different than division defined on integers.
True it has type bool, it's a Boolean. None, the name of the type of None is
NoneType. So, None is actually a value. When a function doesn't return anything,
the value that we get back is actually a value of None, which is an object and
has the type NoneType. The string udacious is a string, its actual type is an
str. You can see that by doing type of udacious or any other string. We call it
a string and it makes sense, that's easier to pronounce, but the actual name of
the type is str. This squiggles here, well, this creates an empty dictionary.
And dictionary has type dict. And finally the brackets, create an empty list,
which has typed list.